hello yes it's exactly a year since the
very first
red heart was painted on this stretch of
wall which runs between lambeth bridge
and westminster bridge here on the south
bank of the river thames directly
opposite the houses of parliament and
every single one of the tens of
thousands of hearts that are on here now
represent the life of someone who has
been lost to covid 19. and today the
people who are gathering here are going
to march to downing street a silent
procession um to deliver a petition
which already has close to 107 000
names on it um calling for this memorial
war which runs about 500 metres in all
to become a permanent memorial a place
for people to come to reflect to
remember
those who've lost their lives and this
of course all on the day as we were just
hearing when fixed penalty notices we're
told are being issued for the breaking
of the law the breaches of these coveted
rules by those working at number 10 and
also
across white hall and i'm joined now by
two sisters who've come all the way from
glasgow today i'm joined by diane divine
and by patricia mccarran and thank you
so much i know it's a very hard day for
you you lost your mum didn't you april
the 9th 2020 and actually someone came
and put the heart on for you originally
tell me about that at that point we
couldn't travel from glasgow we'd do the
heart myself so through the bereavement
group someone put my mom's name on your
heart so it was lovely for that and
then put a thank you on the bereavement
group saying thanks for whoever and that
person got in contact with us so we're
now friends with that person who painted
mum's up there isn't she she was 79
eileen jonathan just getting a picture
there and
and she was she was 79 but she was
fitting well wasn't she got nothing
wrong with her at all yet perhaps so
great
so how important is it why is it so
important to have somewhere like this to
come to what is it about it
it's just
you need to be remembered or not just a
statistic and
it's all these people have suffered the
same thing now the suffering of the good
even and they've all died from the same
reason and the numbers are absolutely
shocking it gives you a real sense of
the numbers doesn't it when you see it
like this
so
today
you're going to go to downing street
and deliver this petition
why is it so important this becomes
a permanent memorial
thank you well
it's got to be visual so
so this all on the day
we know that these fixed penalty notices
are being issued what was your reaction
when you saw this unfold this news
coming out of party after party bring
your own bottle and things like that
very angry it's very disrespectful
yeah to all the families that suffered
the first heart and you're still hurting
we're still grieving
and
some people obviously have just been
cared what's going on around about them
it's just it's a fixed penalty notice
enough as far as you're concerned should
be here just now facing come down and
face it people definitely apology would
have been a fixed penalty notice isn't
and often that that's nothing really uh
i don't think that's i think an apology
in front of the people that have
suffered suffered it would have been
more meaningful
and what about the prime minister
himself but we know that there was all
the calls from to go it all kind of
stepped back when we had
you know the outbreak of the war and
what do you think now now that we're at
the point where we don't know yet but
you know these no these uh fines are
being handed out well i don't think we
can just ignore it because there's
things going on in other parts of the
world because
we're still here
for us so we need to think of ourselves
and i think that call for him to go
still exist okay thank you both so much
just before we go i'm just going to take
you around to
one of the hearts which is just here on
the side of this pillar and it says
mum we never got to say goodbye and i
think that's the point isn't it for so
many people they were in the middle
of a global pandemic there were
restrictions which meant that they
couldn't come to see their loved ones um
in the last moments of their lives while
people were partying and i think that's
why this is frustration and why there is
this demand that this wall remains a
permanent memorial to those who lost
their lives